rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message demand respect over to you Oprah
Winfrey when I first started as a
broadcaster I was 19 very insecure
thrown into television pretending to be
Barbara Walters looking nothing like her
and still going to college so I do all
my classes in the morning from 8:00 to
1:00 and then the afternoon I work from
2:00 to 10:00 and did the 6 o'clock news
and would stay up and study and all that
stuff that you know until 1 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning and then just
start the routine all over again and my
classmates were so jealous of me that I
remember like taking my little hundred
and fifteen dollar paycheck and at the
time I thought was really a lot but
taking 150 dollars and trying to appease
them I would like all wait anytime
anybody needed money I was always
offering oh you need ten dollars or
taking them out for pizza ordering pizza
for the class and things like that
trying to that hold disease - please
that's where it was the worst for me I
think because I wanted to be accepted by
them and could not be because first of
all I didn't have the time they wanted
me to pledge and I didn't have the time
to pledge I was I didn't have the time
to be a part of all the other college
activities or a part of that whole
lifestyle and it was very difficult for
me socially really one of the worst
times of my life because I was trying to
fit in in school and be a part of that
culture but also trying to build a
career in television it's very difficult
for me to even see myself as successful
because I still see myself as in the
process of becoming successful to me
successful is getting to the point where
you are absolutely comfortable with
yourself and it does not matter how many
things you have acquired
the ability to learn to say no and not
to feel guilty about it
to me is about the greatest success I
have achieved the fact that I have you
know in the public side done whatever is
fine it's all a part of a process for
growing for me but to me to have the in
the kind of internal strength and
internal courage it takes to say no I
will not let you treat me this way
is what success is all about it's the
same thing that prevents you from being
abused as a child that prevents you from
being abused as an adult that allows you
to build success for yourself I will not
be treated this way I demand only the
best for myself you are worthy to say no
you were that it's okay if you say no
it's okay if you say no and then people
don't like you that's really okay the
important thing is how you feel about
what you're doing how you feel about
yourself it's a long struggle though
it's a long struggle and I'm just hoping
that you know in the work that I do on
the show and the speaking that I do
around the country and that young people
who are watching this can get the lesson
sooner than I did because it's painful
because you keep repeating it over and
over and over until you get it right and
what I found is that every time you have
to repeat the lesson it gets worse
because it's you know it's I call it God
trying to get your attention the
universe trying to get your attention so
we didn't get your attention the first
time so we're gonna have to hit you a
little harder this time so I'm still
doing it I'm still learning okay seems
worse because it gets worse you train
the people in your life how to treat you
if you are not happy with the way
something is going in your life with how
somebody is treating you it's not their
fault it's not their fault for walking
all over you it's not their fault for
being a loser and eighty-eight or
uncaring it's your fault for allowing it
to happen to you and you need to raise
your standards and teach the people in
your life how to treat you now I'm not
talking about as a child and child abuse
and all those things like at some point
you know you're too young to be able to
make those decisions but if you're not
old you always have a choice you are not
powerless you teach the people in your
life how to treat you and if you're not
happy with it then you need to raise
your standards
one of the things for me as an example
is punctuality I hate when people are
late and I'm never late for things I
value my time time is the most precious
thing that I have and so I value it
immensely and if you are late for
something for me
that's gonna really bother me that's
gonna be a problem and I'll respect your
time in the process as well so when I
first started working with Alex at
Toronto Vince also has an example he
would routinely be late not really late
but fifteen minutes late ten minutes
late five minutes late he'd be late
that's a problem for me
don't be late coming to meet me I value
my time you should value yours as well
and so when it kept happening I locked
the door and he couldn't get in you have
to go work somewhere else you waste even
more time and we had conversations if
you are making a goal to show up at a
certain time and then you show up late
you're missing another goal you're
letting yourself down not just me not
just the people that you're setting
these times up you said you're letting
yourself down if you book the coffee
meeting with me for three o'clock on a
Thursday afternoon and you don't show up
at three o'clock by three o'clock I'm
out because you shouldn't just be there
at three o'clock you really should be
there 15 minutes early because I'm there
15 minutes early you should not be there
at 3 o'clock when I do hangouts on my
youtube channel I do more on the live
channel than the main one if we're
supposed to start at 2 o'clock we
started 2 o'clock I send you the link 10
to 15 minutes before we start if you
don't show up at time at 2 o'clock then
I leave I cancel it and if you showed up
at 2:01 you would have missed it I'm not
there anymore I'm gone no five minute
rule or 10 minute rule or 15 minute rule
I'm gone and that's with some customers
right like that means I don't do
business with some people that means I
lose out on some deals if I'm supposed
to meet somebody at a coffee shop at 3
o'clock and they're not there by 3
o'clock and I leave and they come five
minutes later I'm gone they we sit there
afternoon they're probably not gonna be
super happy about that I may not make a
deal with that person
one if that's the kind of relationship
we're gonna have I don't want to do
business with that person if you're
gonna routinely be late to things I
don't want to deal with you - if we're
gonna reschedule something you're not
going to be late for me the next time
and so you teach the people in your life
how to treat you because you have a new
standard that you value yourself to such
a degree that you say I am not willing
to let you walk all over me anymore you
need to setup a higher wall a higher
barrier and so yes the people around you
may be taking advantage of you they may
be treating you like crap they may be
hurling insults at you you need to stop
allowing it to happen stop blaming them
for their insecurities and their issues
stop blaming them take ownership
stop letting it happen to you the main
respect so the question they today is
I'm curious when was the last time
you've had to raise your standards in
demand respect leave in the comments
below I'm really curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout-out to
Sahana moot Kamala thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my new book the top
ten roses success and taking that
picture and sending it in
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of an
espresso
[Music]
I always say you know worry about being
respected never worry about being liked
because that's the track that's where
people manipulate you and so my kids you
know I did not teach my kids to be liked
I taught them to always live by their
truth and to always respect others and
to always reach to be respected and you
know different people will respect
different things but at the end of the
day my kids have the confidence to be
who they are and that is all as a parent
that will and I can ask of them because
that is where their power and their
strength will come from was in the die
hard office one day and there's a sign
on the on the wall that I adhere to be
Emily now that said be careful of the
toes you step on today for they could be
connected to the ass you'll have to kiss
tomorrow and believe me they're been pas
and other people like when I'm on a
movie set I think everybody is just as
important as I am I treat them that way
so I know pas names I talked to him I
speak to him every day I speak to the
gaffer's I speak to the grips I speak to
all these people and over the years I've
gotten jobs and the producer will show
up and he'll be like you you don't
remember me but I was a PA on our song
song son you were so nice to me that you
know and I was doing this movie I
couldn't help but think you know that
you would be the perfect and that [ __ ]
works out you know or they become
writers or they become directors you
know but it's a collaborative effort I
mean we're we're almost the least
important element of any film because if
[ __ ] ain't putting the lights
up right or the soundman mic is jacked
up it'll mean about what you're doing
cuz nobody can see you or hear you you
know so they can fix that in the mix you
know but everything else has got to work
and you you have to know that one song
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details